held wieder eure mal bammel und heute
gibt es schon wieder ein anrecht vor
lust auf ein bier haben kann
da brauchst du dir für andere ich hab so
lust auf eins aber wir haben keinen
schnee dann brauchst du den magic krimis
garantiert verletzungsfrei der magic
fries eigentlich wie das lasche maker
den ich schon mal vom jahr ausprobiert
aber dass man da als zutaten rein macht
und dafür gibt's nur ein kleines
lustiges handbuch in dem du unten
findest und wie sie zubereitet werde ich
habe mich für cookies in krimis
entschieden nur dass ich das cookies
gegen j
diese verletzung jemals wieder schneien
sollte erstmal brauchen wir den deckel
um die zutaten
was sind das für flaschen wein trinken
alkohol
besteht eigentlich nur aus spaß die
hälfte des wetters weiter steht 100
milliliter sahne
jetzt machen wir das geräusch ich möchte
gerade alle zutaten jetzt kommt der
deckel ab ich habe das nicht sieht sehr
sehr gut aus es üblich die aus es ist
nicht richtig dass vanessa macht dass es
der geschmackstest keine sahne
ich packe es jetzt nochmal mit dem eine
gefriertruhe ja lass es vielleicht
einmal anfrieren oder so und gebt euch
dann später bescheid wenn es dann doch
geklappt hat ansonsten würde ich jetzt
sagen irgendwann später ok vanessa was
ist mit dem eis passiert
die ganze sahne und das einfach mal
alles so ins tiefkühlfach angetan und
eis ist das jetzt wirklich nicht hier
ein eisstück häufig max
was meist kaufen macht es nicht kauft
weiß meistens nicht so teuer
stoppt das video als ich hatte dieses
teil jetzt drei tage im tiefkühlfach und
es hat nichts gebracht also ich weiß
nicht was ich falsch gemacht habe aber
ich habe mich an den zutaten gehalten
reingemacht stadt kekse dann kann es
auch nicht liegen
kaufe es nicht bis zum nächsten mal